so with the death of Wolverine part 3 we
pick up of course where part 2 left off
and with part 3 what we find here is a
scenario whereby Kitty Pryde appears to
have arrived here to help Wolverine and
what Kitty Pryde is basically doing
right now is she has her hand through
the chest of Lady Deathstrike then what
she tells Lady Deathstrike is that if
Katie Pride I guess we solidifies
herself that Death Strike will die and
so Death Strike initially thinks that
Kitty Pryde is bluffing she doesn't
believe that Kitty Pryde will actually
do this and so death strike immediately
turns and begins to attack Kitty Pryde
now it was the two of them were fighting
Kitty Pryde fazes sticks her hand
through lady death strikes hand and then
Reese elyda finds herself and when she
does the result is that Lady Deathstrike
loses her hand and of course at this
point Lady Deathstrike simply just runs
away and so what happens here is Kitty
Pryde turns her attention to Wolverine
and what she does is she gives Wolverine
a regenerative serum now the way that
she explains this to Wolverine this
serum is not nearly as powerful as his
actual healing factor his healing factor
would of course be able to heal him
he'll will rain himself far better than
miss regenerative serum would be able to
but as she explains this regenerative
serum at the very least we'll be able to
patch him up and so what wolverine tells
Kitty Pryde is that it appears as far as
the information he was able to gain from
Lady Deathstrike
that a former villain of both Kitty
Pryde and Wolverine named ogen is
tracking the two of them down now in the
Kitty Pryde and Wolverine series we had
seen them come into conflict with Odin
or with a augen and so Kitty probably
knows who ogen is and so what Kitty
Pryde does is she joins Wolverine as the
two of them go about trying to find
Logan now what we do here is we switch
to Wolverine and Kitty Pryde simply
talking to one another and this is a
very interesting situation and the
reason why is because this gives us some
really in-depth thought into the mindset
of Wolverine after he learns that he had
lost his healing factor and of course
what Kitty Pryde asks Wolverine is what
it is that he knows up to this point
and what Wolverine tells us is
effectively everything that had taken
place over the death of Wolverine parts
1 & 2 where he says that somewhere along
the line somebody had put out a contract
on Wolverine or at least that was the
initial reception that Wolverine had
then while Wolverine had gone about the
process of killing virtually everyone
who had shown up to try to I guess cash
in this contract that eventually
Wolverine realized that the only way for
him to bring this to an end was to
actually seek out the person who would
initiated this contract and kill that
person or at the very least bring the
contract to an end and so what he says
is that with this idea of him losing his
healing factor and it's not really a bad
thing and kitty pryde is a little
shocked to hear about this she's a
little shocked in to hear Wolverine say
that he's not that upset about looting
and losing his healing factor and this I
think is when we get some really cool
in-depth I guess analysis into the
character of Wolverine what Wolverine
tells us is that he had effectively for
the longest time since he had his
healing factor felt as though he was
simply stuck in time he was stuck in
place that he would never really aged at
the same pace as everybody else and
because of that he would basically
outlive everyone but more so than that
he could never really live because he
could always say as he explains it that
he had basically until the end of time
to make up for his mistakes and so what
he wants to do here is bring this bounty
to an end to bring this contract to an
end kill whoever it was that had started
this whole thing and then simply
disappear and live his life and die in
peace and so what happens here is that
Kitty Pryde confesses her affections for
Wolverine she confesses her love for
Wolverine now Wolverine immediately
rebukes her he says their relationship
was never like this that the two of them
never had any kind of romantic chemistry
as far as he was concerned the
relationship between Wolverine and Kitty
Pryde and historically speaking when we
look at the comics is really more on the
order of a brother and a sister and so
what happens here is Kitty Pryde
initially seems to resent the attitude
that Wolverine has given her either she
simply comments on the idea that maybe
Kitty Pryde isn't as beautiful as other
women like Jean Grey maybe Kitty Pryde
liked some element but then Wolverine
begins to pick up on what's going on
here any
Eliza's this is not really kitty pryde
now this person is in fact bogan now
again as we have previously discuss was
a long-standing villain of Wolverine and
Kitty Pryde but ogen has the ability to
possess the minds and to possess the
bodies of other people and this is what
he's done with Kitty Pryde he's simply
taken over her body and so what happens
here is Wolverine and Ogun begin to
engage in conflict with one another and
as they're fighting of course Wolverine
is throw into or thrown into a building
which houses samurai armor and samurai
repet weaponry and so what he does is
Don this armor and weaponry and begin
fighting Shogun of fighting ogun and as
ogen and Wolverine are fighting one
another o genstat Kitty Pryde is also
fighting back against his control and so
what's basically happening here is that
again is fighting a war on two fronts
he's fighting against Kitty Pryde trying
to retake her body and he's fighting
against Wolverine on the outside and so
eventually Kitty Pryde is able to
overcome against control and Ogun spirit
leaves her body and takes off and so
what happens is Wolverine initially goes
to to comfort Kitty Pryde but Kitty
Pryde tells him to leave but before
Wolverine takes off Kitty Pryde says she
had overheard a name while she was being
possessed by Ogun and that name was dr.
Abraham Cornelius the person that had
first given Wolverine his adamantium and
so what we do here is we pick up with
Wolverine as he's trying to find ogen
and he eventually tracks ogen down who's
possessed another body but he tracks him
down to a warehouse and when Wolverine
enters the warehouse he sees what
appears to be a giant vat and inside of
this vat is the body of a person named
cyborg and Watauga new guns to tell
wolverine here is effectively what he
knows
o genstat somewhere along the line again
this contract was initiated but that
Wolverine is again not the only person
that's being pursued here that this
person dr. Abraham Cornelius is going
after anything at a mantium based he's
going after statues he's going after
people he's going after artifacts
anything and everything that possesses
adamantium but the strange thing here is
that Wolverine is the only person that
was explicitly laid out in the contract
that had to be brought in alive nobody
else or I guess everybody else could be
killed with the
exception of wool rain and so when
Wolverine asks a little more information
what again says is that all of these
people all these artifacts and all these
things that are in some way connected or
in possession of adamantium are being
taken to a place in Nevada called
Paradise Valley and so what oaken does
here is he begins to I guess kind of try
to lure Wolverine or try to get
Wolverine to leave and the reason behind
this is ogen explains is because his
spirit is tired due to the conflict that
had taken place between himself and
kitty pryde it had made him very very
weak and so what he wants to do is
simply leave and so what he tells
Wolverine is that if Wolverine doesn't
leave that he's going to throw his body
or throw this physical body into the
acid pit and it's going to kill that
person
now Wolverine is initially a little bit
hesitant here and so what what ogen says
is that he'll give will rein several
syringes full of a regenerative serum if
Wolverine leaves now Wolverine turns
this down of course he likes the idea
again of being able to grow old but what
he tells ogen is that ogen needs to tell
dr. Abraham Cornelius that Wolverine is
coming for him and so Wolverine leaves
to resume ibly go after dr. Cornelius
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and wring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates for marvel explained and talk to
me directly